movie theaters desperately want you back
in the cinema
it's going to cost you more than ever
America's largest movie chain AMC says
ticket prices will soon be based on get
this seat location meaning the crappy
ones in the front will be cheaper while
the more desirable seats in the middle
will cost more
Greg is this going to make you go to the
movies more absolutely because there's
nothing I like better than lording my
privilege over other people check out my
seat everybody I'm talking about the
movie seat although that ain't bad
either huh check it out
judges judges is this a good way from a
capitalistic standpoint when they're
trying to get people to come back to
raise prices in the theater no nobody
wants to go back anyway you can stream
everything at home and you can you don't
have to you don't have to pay six
dollars for a soda oh and you're really
streaming yeah
Jesse Jr wants to go and sit in the
middle you're going to go Jesse yeah
I'll sit in the middle I'll pay extra
because I can't sit in the front because
I have neck problems I can't crank my
neck up for three hours like that oh
it's I'm gonna have to see a
chiropractor so I'll pay more not to see
a chiropractor what about the bed bugs
go see a doctor maybe take your
chiropractor to the movie theater Dana
what's your thoughts on this I'm just
not sure if taking the Southwest
Airlines model and taking it over to the
movie theater is the best business
decision I would rethink that
oh wow seems like they're going to have
to I want to Brian kill Mead I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now